ANNA PATTERSON: My dad was a
NASA engineer, so he brought
us for a tour at Johnson Space
Center, and they asked my
brother what he wanted to be,
and he said an astronaut.
And then they asked me
what I wanted to be,
and I said an astronaut.
And they said, what?
Girls can't be astronauts.
In their mind, they
were right.
They just didn't realize that
the future would be different.
GAYATHRI RAJAN: It's hard
when you're young,
when you're a teenager.
There's a lot of peer
pressure to conform.
ANGELA LAI: There is a certain
stigmatism to being a woman in
technology.
It doesn't seem to be something
that you do.
JEN FITZPATRICK: I didn't want
to be stuck at my desk,
programming on a computer 8, 10
hours a day, every day for
the rest of my life.
That's just not how
I saw myself.
But so much of it is also
collaborating with other
people, and brainstorming,
and problem solving.
GAYATHRI RAJAN: It's
working as a team.
It's building things together.
ANGELA LAI: It always
feels like play.
It doesn't feel like work.
SUSAN WOJCICKI: I'm always
surprised that there are not
more women going into tech,
because I think it's growing,
and there are just lots
of opportunities.
ANGELA LAI: There is no road
blocks, you know, being a
woman in technology.
PAVNI DIWANJI: There were
a lot of naysayers.
They're like, don't do that.
You're never going
to be successful.
And so one of the things I
learned very quickly is you've
got to stay focused, and you
just have to believe in
yourself and just
make it happen.
GAYATHRI RAJAN: I come into work
everyday excited about
the challenges and the
possibilities.
JEN FITZPATRICK: It's incredibly
satisfying to know
that you're doing something that
has that type of impact
and that type of reach.
SHERRY LISTGARTEN: You really
feel like you're doing
something that's helpful and
that's making a difference.
PAVNI DIWANJI: I'm able to
create something that most
universities in the world use.
You know, how impactful
is that?
GAYATHRI RAJAN: Five million
businesses use the products
that I've been working on.
ANNA PATTERSON: Every time
you type in a query,
you're using my code.
And that means that
I'm reaching
billions of people a day.
JEN FITZPATRICK: You see the
impact every single day on
real people, and your friends,
and your family, and that's
just magical.
MEGAN SMITH: Hello, welcome to
Women Techmakers live on
location at Google I/O. It's
incredible to be here.
We have a fabulous lineup
of speakers.
We've set up this session as a
series of lightning talks.
So we want to ignite and inspire
with topics around
search, of course, but also
Google Glass, some product
insights, AI knowledge,
and other topics.
I've asked all of our speakers
to tell personal stories as
they walk through these topics,
and we have a bit of a
theme of past, present,
and future.
But before we start, I don't
know if my slide thing is
advancing, so I'm going
to come over here.
Hello?
Sorry, guys-- there.
So this is the lineup.
And before we start, I want to
talk a little bit about why we
started Women Techmakers.
Last night we had a fabulous
gathering of the women, a
pre-gathering of the women who
are here at I/O. And we might
be in the minority,
but we're fierce.
And it was really fun, a good
social experience, and we want
to build community amongst
women, with our male
colleagues.
We also are working on
visibility, and women are
largely invisible in technology
is part of our feeling.
And so our goal is to
increase visibility.
Our industry is probably 10 or
20% technical women, sometimes
a little higher.
We want to get to 50%.
We want to match
the population.
Products are just better
when they're
built by diverse teams.
Companies are better.
The world is better.
And that's part of our goal.
I wanted to give a shout out
to real progress that's
happening this year.
Sheryl Sandberg, who is a
fabulous colleague, Google
alum now, leading Facebook with
Mark, has really driven
the national and international
conversation up.
We need to be talking
about these things.
I don't know if people
are familiar
with the Maker series.
Maker.com, AOL, and PBS
have launched this.
It's the modern women's rights
movement's history,
documentaries, and really
shining a light into actual
fabulous stories, the back
stories, on women that you
haven't really heard before.
And you just saw a video clip,
a montage of something we've
done, which is called Makers at
Google down here, which you
can get to on
google.com/diversity/women.
We really want people to know
the stories of the women who
build YouTube, the women who
build Android, the women who
build Search.
And so we've launched this
series starting today.
As part of celebrating what's
going on and some momentum, we
have a long way still to go, but
we've come a long way in
really upping the
conversation.
I just want to shout out to some
of the giants we stand on
the shoulders of.
This is Katherine Switzer, first
woman to run the Boston
Marathon officially.
I encourage you to
watch her story.
The race director tried to
rip her numbers off.
It's on Makers.com.
And this is Elizabeth Cady
Stanton, and she's delivering
the Declaration of Sentiments in
the mid 1800s at the first
Women's Rights Convention back
when women weren't allowed to
go to university and were not
allowed to do many things.
How many people in this room
have ever heard of the
Declaration of Sentiments?
There's one, two.
Looks like for people on
Livestream, we're probably at
about 10%, which brings me to
the point I want to make,
again, about visibility
and invisibility.
We really have a problem
with how visible
technical women are.
And so I want to jump into two
things before we start.
Sometimes you're lucky-- you
know, there's symptoms of a
problem, and sometimes there's
roots of a problem.
And I stumbled off across this
when I met Geena Davis, the
famous Academy Award-winning
actress.
Geena was watching TV with her
children when they were young
and she just-- as an
actress, she could
see that TV was biased.
And she'd say in the industry,
there's not enough women and
girls on children's
television.
People would say, yes, of
course, there's plenty, like
Dora, the "Scooby-Doo" girls,
lots of people.
But then she thought,
no, there's not.
Let's measure.
You manage what you measure.
So she measured it together with
USC Annenberg, and the
studies were showing-- and
they had grad students
counting by hand--
it's actually three to one
across all of children's
television, the corpus of
children's television of men
and boys versus girls.
And so the girls aren't equally
represented, and you
see amazing things that you
wouldn't even notice, but how
many women in the whole ocean
in the film "Nemo"?
How many monsters or muppets
were in "Sesame Street" who
were girls until the '90s?
That would be zero.
"Nemo"?
One.
So we're not accurately
depicting the world, and we're
skewing it.
So one of things we've been
lucky to do-- and also, one
more stat, the 80% stat.
80% of the jobs that were held
by characters in the
television our children watched,
were held by male
characters.
So we taught our kids that girls
and women don't do STEM,
which it just doesn't happen to
be true, as we'll show in
this session.
And so we really need
to get in here.
We are now working with Geena on
trying to automate some of
this so we could have a gender
disparity measurement ability
to look at our media.
And I encourage everybody who
has technical background, look
at ways we could use technology
to count bias so we
can measure and see things.
The last thing I'll point out
before we start about things--
oh, one more example.
This is so insidious, like our
bias, that I was looking in a
catalog recently, and this was
a dresser for a boy and a
dresser for a girl.
And the colors are different,
but really, the big difference
to me that I saw because of
being aware of Geena's work
was that the boy got
the microscope
and the girl didn't.
So as you now know this fact,
you're going to notice it
everywhere.
And it's something we
need to work on.
And if we could use technology
to help ourselves see it, we
could get out of this historic
bias that we inherited.
The last thing I would say
before we start is around
becoming visible, includes not
only seeing the technical
women who are here today, but
also the historic women.
I don't know how many people
recognize some of the people
on these slides.
Yeah, I see a couple hands,
but really probably these
people are pretty
unknown to you.
Ada Lovelace is representing
the Doodle.
She's from 1800s.
She's actually the first person
in world history to
think of programming
something.
She is the founder
of our industry.
There's the women who were
Astronaut Corps.
Nobody knew about them.
We know about the men.
Some of the most decorated
Americans, of course, are the
astronauts from the "Apollo"
and "Mercury" times.
They were there.
They just weren't
allowed to fly.
Grace Hopper, this is the
Whirlwind project at MIT.
The Bletchley code crackers, the
Enigma code crackers from
World War II, more than half
women, mathematicians.
Hedy Lamar, Hedy Lamar helps you
have your cell phone work.
And up on the top, there's
a wonderful thing that
Singularity University launched
last week and
encouraged all of us to help.
It's a crowd-sourced
history idea.
And so innovatingwomen.org,
please go there.
Please help capture
these stories.
And last, I want to
point to this
picture down on the bottom--
University of Pennsylvania,
World War II.
I want to bring Kathy
Kleiman on stage.
She's going to share an
extraordinary story from
history that I was lucky Brad
Feldman alerted me to.
He's here.
Kathy.
[APPLAUSE]
KATHY KLEIMAN: Thank
you so much, Megan.
I'm thrilled to be here with all
of you today, and I have
an amazing story to
share with you.
But first, I have
two questions.
The first one is, does anybody
here know who invented the
first sort routine?
It was Betty Holberton.
Another question, who invented
the first software
application?
That was Betty Holberton, too.
We don't know about her because
she was never written
into formal computer history.
In fact, her story was almost
completely untold
for a very long time.
I know because I found it.
Can we go to the
slide, please?
Thank you.
No, because I found it.
When I was an undergraduate and
a computer programmer, I
felt very isolated.
I didn't see women around me.
I didn't see them
in my classes.
as faculty in my
computer science classes.
So I turned to history to see
if I could find role models,
and I found this picture.
This is of the ENIAC, the first
all electronic digital
computer it was a secret project
during World War II at
the University of
Pennsylvania.
And when I found the pictures,
the men were in the captions.
That's J. Presper Eckert and
John Mauchly on the left and
right front, and they're the
co-inventors of the ENIAC,
very famous.
But there are women in these
pictures, and I wanted to know
who they were, and they weren't
in the captions.
So I took the picture, and I
went to a leading computer
historian, and I asked
her who they were.
And she said, the refrigerator
ladies.
I said, refrigerator lady?
She said, they're models posed
in front of the machine to
make it look good, like the
Frigidaire models who used to
open the new refrigerators
with such a flourish.
Well, they didn't look
like models to me.
These women look like they
belong in this picture, and
they look like they know exactly
what they're doing.
So I set out to find
them, and I did.
That's Jean Bartik in the far
back, and Ruth Lichterman
Teitelbaum in the front.
They were two of the original
ENIAC programmers, and I was
thrilled to learn that all six
of the original programmers
were women.
So now I'm going to
take a pause.
Thanks to the wonderful Women
Techmakers, I've been able to
bring you a short video of the
ENIAC programmers telling you
a bit of their story
themselves.
It's part of oral histories
I've collected over many
years, and I'm thrilled to be
able to share this with you.
[APPLAUSE]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-From the very beginning, you're
going to be a first in
a lot of things.
-I've never since never been in
as exciting an environment.
We knew we were pushing
back frontiers.
-In February of 1946, six months
after World War II had
ended, America learned
of a secret Army
project called ENIAC.
It was the first
all-electronic digital computer.
Yet the tale of ENIAC's
programming by a group of
young women has been all but
erased from computer history.
During World War II, the US had
assembled a crew of nearly
100 mathematically trained women
whose official title was
Computer, women who were
computing complex ballistic
trajectory equations by hand and
using mechanical desktop
calculators.
In the spring of 1945, six were
selected to figure out
how to program the
ENIAC machine--
Fran Bilas, Betty Jean Jennings,
Ruth Lichterman,
Kathleen McNulty, Betty Snyder,
Marlyn Wescoff.
-We were computing ballistic
tables on a hand calculator.
We were computing, and
we were computers.
-There logical diagrams of the
ENIAC, and we were supposed to
study them to figure out
how to program it.
The ENIAC was a son of
a bitch to program.
-ENIAC became legend.
Eckert and Mauchly
became famous.
However, the ENIAC programmer
story, the story of these six
women founders who created the
first sort routine, first
software application, and became
the first teachers of
modern programming
was never told.
Their work dramatically altered
computing in the 1940s
and 1950s as they paved
the path to
modern computer science.
-At that time, the emphasis was
on the invention of the
ENIAC, I mean, developing, and
the mechanics, the hardware.
-We were like fighter pilots.
I mean, here was this great,
great machine, but you
couldn't just take any ordinary
pilot and stick them
into a fighter pilot and
say, go to it now, man.
I mean, that was not the
way it was going to be.
-I had a fantastic life.
Everything I did was the
beginning of something new.
-I really loved working
with those girls.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
KATHY KLEIMAN: Aren't
they amazing?
[APPLAUSE]
KATHY KLEIMAN: And their work
didn't stop with ENIAC.
They became the first teachers
of modern programming.
They became the first modern
professional programmers.
And Betty and Jean went on to
program BINAC and UNIVAC, the
first commercial computers, and
they created innovative
tools that changed the face
of programming forever.
Absolutely amazing.
And in a very nice twist,
Betty Holberton actually
interviewed Grace Hopper
to invite her down to
Eckert-Mauchly Computer
Corporation, the first
commercial modern computing
company, and
Grace, of course, accepted.
So now--
thank you.
So now, today, I have an amazing
announcement to make.
After so many years of
recording their oral
histories, researching their
accomplishments, and working
so closely with the ENIAC
programmers, I'm thrilled to
tell you that and I'm thrilled
to announce here, that final
funding has finally been put
together so that I can produce
a documentary and finish my book
on the ENIAC programmers
and share the story
with all of you.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERS]
KATHY KLEIMAN: This is happening
because Megan Smith
introduced me to two remarkable
technical women of vision--
Anne Wojcicki and Lucy
Southworth Page.
And they're providing wonderful
support through
their foundations, The Brin
Wojcicki Foundation and the
Donor Advised Fund on behalf
of Lucy Southworth Page.
And I really want to applaud
them, because this is amazing.
[APPLAUSE]
KATHY KLEIMAN: And thanks to
this support, I will be in
production this summer with the
Paul Freeman Film Group,
and we will be producing a
documentary, and we'll have a
book for you very,
very shortly.
I can't wait to share the
story in its full form.
And now I want to share just a
personal story about how I
learned firsthand what history
and visibility can do to shape
our viewpoints.
Ten years ago, when my son was
five, he came over to me with
a very confused look
on his face.
He'd grown up with my work on
the ENIAC programmers, and
he'd even met and actually
played with four of the
original six ENIAC
programmers.
And he looked upset/ and he
said, mom, I know that women
can be computer programmers,
but can men be
programmers, too?
I assured him that, of course,
women and men could be
programmers, and in fact,
technology was better when we
created it together.
And when I left him two nights
ago, he was programming.
And so what I want to do and
conclude is say stay tuned for
more about the ENIAC
programmers.
And please join me in the quest
to capture wonderful
stories of women in
technology, so we
don't lose any more.
And on behalf of all of us,
I want to thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MEGAN SMITH: And first off,
thank you to all of our
amazing lightning speakers.
You guys were incredible.
[APPLAUSE]
MEGAN SMITH: And also to
Stephanie, and Phoebe, and
Mimi, and Sinead, and Judith,
who helped us put all this
together with the amazing
I/O team.
Just quickly, Larry talked
about thinking big.
We've been talking about the
idea of moon shots, you know,
going 10x instead of 1x.
And so we--
my colleague Astro and I have
launched this site in this
sort of goal to have the meme
of moon shot thinking be
something that more of us do.
So Solve For X is this
idea of there's a big
problem in the world.
There's some kind of crazy
technology that is there.
It feels like science fiction,
or there's a reuse of
something old that we just
might be able to use as a
radical solution to solve big
problems in the world, be they
self-driving cars, or poverty,
or water, or just
more fun for everybody.
And the main thing about this
is that it's on the web.
It's open.
And so there's lots of proposals
already up, and
we've partnered with the X
Prize and TED and Arizona
State University, Singularity,
this great set of movies from
GE's Focus Forward about moon
shots that people are taking.
And so we're just trying to get
the conversation going and
really celebrate people who are
starting, or who are in
process of moon shot, because we
always celebrate the people
who made it, but we really
want to get more about
collaborating and teamwork.
Bill Clinton calls the 21st
century the century of
creative collaboration.
And really, the web and
all the things, we
already know that.
We already feel that.
So that's what Solve
For X is about.
And along those lines, there's
an idea that we have as part
of it-- my clicker's
not working--
about your x, like x is a
problem in the world or
something you're passionate
about.
So I was really lucky as a
student to get to take
acoustics at MIT from Professor
Bose, as in Bose speakers.
He was an extraordinary
professor.
And at one point during our
classes, he paused, and he
went into a lecture
about life.
And one of the key things he
said is, you know, you guys
are really talented.
You're doing great things.
You're going for it.
The key thing now for you is,
figure out what are you
passionate about.
In some ways, what's your x?
What do you care about?
What do you want to work on?
Because if you find that,
you're going to be
unstoppable, and you will do
extraordinary things to help
people make things great
in the world.
And I think that the women who
we've heard from have found
their x, and I hope that
everybody will be
thinking that way.
I welcome everybody to
stay afterwards.
I think Susan has to
catch a plane, but
everybody else is here.
There's a bunch of great
websites up, like the
makers.com site.
And in fact, today I heard--
somebody just told me that
Susan's story is up on the
homepage of AOL, so
she's one of the
Makers, and she's there.
And again, we've launched Google
Makers at Google, and
we hope that other companies and
other organizations will
start telling the stories,
which leads me back to
visibility.
And let's make people visible.
Help us do it.
And thank you so much
for being here.
[APPLAUSE]